I also have a bottle of cocoa tree at all on hand, so what's cocoa tree at all?
So remember, the vitamin E molecule found in nature has four outer shells.
Those are called Tocofferol's, their labeled alpha beta and gamma delta Tocofferol.
Those are the four outer shells you look at at a microscope.
Then there's four inner molecules of the vitamin E groupied,
and those are called Tocotreotols.
The Tocotreotols are also alpha beta gamma delta Tocotreotol.
So it has been shown that the delta Tocotreotol is the most important for protecting cells
for protecting your arteries, for helping with your brain.
Delta Tocotreotol is essential. That's why I like so many of our private label products
from Design for Health. I have a delta Tocotreotol base.
Delta Tocotreotol is also a fat, so it's a great to use it as a base for supplements instead of having
to use what we were talking about last week, the magnesium sterate, or something like that,
that will help keep the product from binding. So you're using a fat, and you're using it in a fat
soluble solution then. So the delta Tocotreotol can be really good to help pull out radiation.
Delta Tocotreotol can help protect your cells. Delta Tocotreotreotol is the key component
for arterial disease. It can help relax your smooth muscles of your artery. It's really a great
component. So how much do you take of that? I don't know the product that you have, but you literally
can't take too much of it. So that is the key component of vitamin E. You hear my vitamin E is good
for your heart. Well, only if you're using whole food vitamin E that has all the Tocotreotols
and the Tocopharols, or really if you're just using the Delta Tocotreotol, that it's good for your
heart. If you're using the Tocoparol so much of the cheap supplements that you'd buy in the store,
you'd be vitamin E, and then you look at it as alpha or mix Tocopharols. Well, that is just
completely worthless. It's good for your skin to open up the capsule, spread it on your hands,
but it's not going to be good for the rest of your body. It's not how you'd get vitamin E in nature.
That's why cheap vitamins are cheap.